Ben Schwartz from House of Lies Parks
and Rec also rejected jokes about all
the wonderful stuff one of the absolute
funniest people I know
ah thank you so much for being here
thank you so much for having me
how'd you ever put this on sorry I
couldn't I couldn't hear you I was
wearing my my traditional interview your
phones so anything could happen on the
show I guess right this is one of those
everything happened shows oh cool
what are you listening to kid I just
it's actually kiddin play it's funny
that you said kid yeah in one kid plays
oh yeah yeah this one
what's your car let's get let's get this
listen this thing going mm-hmm let's get
this thing go and let's get that loose
blows OH
it's easier for me than when you get it
you go and the girls dakshana let's get
this thing out
when the blow is show do you wanna
listen to it oh it's just positive
affirmations from you to yourself you're
good enough at saying mmm air looks
great
hmm we're polkadot socks did you
remember smart okay always do you wear a
condom when you're flaccid ya know and
then be the best Pete you could be
Conniff lass be the best Pete what's the
point of wearing a condom when your
flaccid she's kind of like you know when
you're a kid and they do the parachute
yes to go in your lender right so far
it's not gonna make sense keep going
keep going keep going on with your ends
here you went under I was always the kid
that was like what if I just linger and
the first you would come down on me I
just remain on top and that's the
feeling I like to give them a little
peek cool let me let me swim around no
pay do you name you dick no I've never
named my dick I don't either but also
what you just did and also don't you
think we should give it a more masculine
strong bigger name than little Pete well
I like to set the bar low oh and then
when they see if they go this isn't bad
little or they go more like regular size
peach so you have sex with cartoon
characters if you want to get Matt way
so male cartoon characters no it's a
lady you okay yes sir
let's see what person or you can't say
the person's name oh my god for what for
your full name witches
engaged to me totally different type of
uh card una never seen it before it's
adult big in Japan can't do another
sombody
come after it's nuts out I didn't do
nothing no that could be anything
yeah you're just talking to me I'm a man
I'm from Maine that's a whole depend on
me or you can ruin you can change this
arm like you know like me far away I see
your cast along the clouds are you in
there yeah okay you change the to
different song issued by two different
places
yeah okay but sing a song about a small
dog I got a tiny dog I sleep with him
but when he bites my tush I punch him in
the chair I'd punch him in the I got a
bird of dog you ping the tiny sling he's
only got three legs and one broken wing
I got a dead dog I dream in the furnace
you